two brothers granted parole and released
from prison last month are now accused
of murdering a man just weeks later it
is a murder case our eight news now
investigators brought you first our own
David charns here now with the details
all new tonight
the Nevada Department of Corrections
released Adam deeg from custody on
December 9th Daniel dig his brother
followed on December 16th by the end of
the month police accused both brothers
of murder appreciate you considering me
go home and get a chance to change my
life I'm looking forward to getting out
and being able to better my life and put
this all behind me that was their parole
hearings 42-year-old Daniel D was more
than halfway through his sentence on
drug-related charges when he went before
the board in September you're at the
habitual criminal already so you sit in
front of the judge again you're not
going to see the outside for a very very
long time two months earlier his younger
brother 37 year old Adam deeg was
nearing the end of his sentence for
kidnapping most important thing that's
actually in your control is to stay out
of trouble and you did that right the
board denied Adam Dean parole in 2020
citing a need for more anger and
aggression classes I have all this time
that
I've made myself into a different person
okay documents the eight news now
investigators obtained revealed the
board granted both brothers parole for
Adam deeg they said quote the case
factors do not suggest that the inmate
would be a danger to Public Safety for
Daniel deeg the board noted a
significant criminal history but stable
release plans weeks after their release
the brothers allegedly stomped on
40-Year-Old Eugene grinnell's head two
days later on December 28th Grinnell
died from his injuries in addition to
murder charges each brother also faces
penalties for violating parole they both
have preliminary hearings scheduled for
next month I'm David charns 8 News Now
and the eight news now investigators
asked the parole board for comment on
the brothers release they did not hear
back